good morning Hank it's Tuesday so you
made a 15 part video that I responded to
with the 16 part video because I thought
your video had 16 parts and then you
made another 15 part video so here are
16 things I love about being outside now
Hank as you know I am a longtime
opponent of outside our ancestors made
extraordinary sacrifices for millennia
to create inside and then we just
dishonor all of that work by willfully
going outside but that noted there is a
lot I like about being outside beginning
with the irregularly shaped polygons
that the sky forms through the trees I
love daddy longlegs how is a creature
like you even real this honeysuckle tree
is invasive and horrible but I love the
way it bends toward the light I love the
mighty White River here in Indianapolis
so Hank Indianapolis was created by
politicians who wanted to put the
capital city of Indiana in the
geographical middle of Indiana and they
were like oh that place looks good it's
on the banks of the mighty white river
and that was important in the early 19th
century you had to be on some kind of
navigable waterway to like get stuff to
your town but it turns out that in many
places the white river is like six
inches deep which is how Indianapolis
came to be the largest American city not
on a navigable waterway
I love geese and their little goslings I
also love Ryan Gosling but that's a
different video I love that downy
woodpecker that's in there somewhere I
love turtles
by turtle sorry if I scared you I love
flowers contemporary flowers like a
collaboration among humans and plants
and bees boy Hank do we need to
collaborate better with plants and bees
I love bubbles and they're just not the
same inside I love peeing outside for
the record I'm not doing it right now
I'm just saying I love that feeling it's
like I too am an animal I love like
weird swamps that feel undiscovered they
make me feel like an explorer
I love snails also while I have great
admiration for the hard-working
chemistry majors in the artificial smell
business there's nothing quite like the
actual smell of outside I know I'm
starting to sound like the nature
enthusiasts I've always reviled but
these leaves just smell so good I just
got a mosquito bite on my cheek and now
I probably have West Nile virus so
thanks mosquitoes for reminding me what
I don't love about outside I love that
like when I'm looking for coyotes and
great blue herons and all that kind of
stuff sometimes I'll just see Henry and
he'll be like dad dad dad look at this
Moss he and Dallas always remind me that
with the right level of attentiveness
everything is amazing
I love tiny little trees forest is big
and mostly without light and you
probably won't make
tiny little tree but I wish you luck I
love trees that lean out over the water
they're doomed but they keep going I
guess most of what I like about nature
Hank is its ability to go on no matter
what I find that quite inspirational
I'll see you on Friday
Oh God
ruined a perfectly good outro this guy
stupid nature always tripping me